[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah no y'all don't know I can flow
yatin or I can flow anyways welcome back
to another solo bonus solo riffing this
week I just got finished taping lights
out that's why our mom I'm kind of
gussied up maybe you saw this if you saw
the lights out already because I've
already aired and then this episode's
gonna come out but I'm just trying to do
more these quick 30 minutes solo riffing
episodes you know what I mean so I'm
actually gonna let me put the timer on
so we don't go over so I know where I'm
at right now you don't I mean just put
the timer let's set the timer for 30
minutes 30 minutes make it yeah this is
the timer for 30 minutes here we go but
anyways before we even start the episode
I wanna give a shout out to one of my
sponsors with a quick commercial sup
y'all this Erik Griffin Erik Griffin
gaming you know my game I'm a big time
gamer so I got this gaming chair it was
sent to me by a win race and that's ewi
n ra ce ing calm they sent me the chair
for free they wanted me to test it out
I've been using it for like three or
four weeks and now I'm here to tell you
what
think about it it's great lumbar support
pillow on the rest here of the headrest
it's super comfortable and swivel the
arms are adjustable I highly recommend
this chair I'm a big guy is super
comfortable for me
get 30% off of you use promo code Eric
30% off use promo code hearing I highly
suggest you get this chair just click
the link down below or go to e win
racing comm it's a dope chair thanks
y'all for sending it to me
and I suggest you get one too remember
Eric Griffin gaming check it out we
highly endorse evening rates but anyways
thanks for listening to all my episodes
are here from a girlfriend but I thought
I'd come out I'm trying to do more
little special solar ones people ask me
like we do to deliver zones and Here I
am I love doing this whole episodes so
what happened this week that I even
wanted to do it was like Chris Vaughn I
don't know if y'all order food from like
GrubHub dad door - ubereats are these
kind of places right so you know I'm
just I'm just putting it out have pride
in your job no matter what your job is
you should have pride in it okay you
know even if it's not something you
really want to do it's like a stopover
while you're trying to do other things
so you trying to make ends meet I get it
that's what driving uber is that's what
delivering Amazon orders are all that
but damn you signed up for it just [ __ ]
ain't government assigned so have some
pride so it's my girlfriend's birthday
the other day and like you know we
ordered return to order some food lace
she wants to get like a little something
and I'm like okay let's order right so
then you looking at the map this is on
door - you're looking at the map you see
the person come they show you all
they're picking it up the food it's very
detailed although they're waiting for
the food oh they got the food they're on
the way to you and then you can kind of
see the map where they're like sorta in
my building I live in like this complex
it's got a bunch of like condo type
complex right so it's very simple it's a
square and you follow the numbers you
know what I mean like my apartment
number is a you know it's not like this
[ __ ] is like 75 then the next number is
to know you just follow the [ __ ]
numbers right anyway person comes in I'm
waiting and waiting no call nothing and
it looks like they got in without
getting buzzed in so they're in there in
and then I get a message on the app it
says food was delivered thank you for
your order and I'm like yellow food
hasn't been delivered so I call cuz you
have like you could call then they hook
you up some house not the real number
but you call no answer I'm texting like
yeah where the hell are you
oh I'm I tried to deliver it I you know
I I couldn't this is what the
[ __ ] was saying like uh uh you
know you only have a certain number time
and when you can't deliver you have to
leave I'm like what you didn't [ __ ]
try to deliver it I said the
instructions I leave very specific
instructions well they're not very
specific it's with this person saying on
the text messages I'm like what the [ __ ]
you talking about the whole complex is a
square you just go around you follow the
numbers I think the [ __ ] is a scam now
I'm starting to realize it because it's
really your word against theirs like
these [ __ ] delivery people could be
like you know what I actually like this
food and this is my last delivery of the
day so let me just be like yeah you know
I couldn't find it I tried to deliver it
and then they got some free [ __ ] food
that's what they're doing out there you
know they're like oh yeah I tried to
deliver and then they don't care you
call the GrubHub or whatever the place
is you called or - she's like yo um yeah
then they show up you know and and I
don't want to credit my [ __ ] is like no
I don't want to credit I want my money
back cuz I don't know if I want to use
your service again door - I want my
money back
so and I realize it's not even their
fought they provide a service here's
this service we want to provide for you
I don't want to leave my house that's
why I [ __ ] ordered so immediately
like when his lady's running around her
name was Wendy okay [ __ ] you Wendy [ __ ]
so mad at her anyway so now you order
food and hope point to order our food is
you don't want to leave your place okay
that's the whole point so immediately I
got an attitude any time any driver is
like yo can you meet me outside no if I
wanted to leave the house I would have
just gone to the store I would have gone
to the restaurant the whole point of me
making this order is for you to come to
my [ __ ] door that's why I made
the order in the first place you know
yeah I'm finna keystore what but I'm
paying for a service
I want that service
anyway so this is that you don't even
call she just and then she says oh I
took a picture of where it is I left it
by the mailbox so now I gotta put pants
on and go out to the freakin mailbox of
course this [ __ ] ain't there and now
she's texting me back and forth trying
to act like oh I didn't do that and and
sending me screenshots of her phone
about how she tried to call me and like
I'm like what are you talk about I got
no call from you lady I screenshot my
[ __ ] sent it to her like where's your
call [ __ ] where you'll call at you I
don't see your call on here and then I
just was getting myself all worked up
and I realize again the whole [ __ ] is a
scam I realized this [ __ ] is a scam okay
so you got people who are doing this
they don't want to do it they think they
better than the job I mean let's be
honest nobody's waking up one day being
like you know what I think I want to
order deliver fast food to people or
deliver shitty meals to people you know
because and make like a little bit of
money and a little bit of tip you know
so I get it it ain't the best job but
you signed up for the [ __ ] so I could
see people being like having no pride in
the job and they go you know what I know
what I'm gonna do I'm just gonna be like
I like to smell this food you know what
I mean I like to smell this so we gonna
just I'm just gonna keep this then I'm
gonna be like I tried to order it and
they wouldn't answer they could say
whatever the [ __ ] they want actually
they could be like oh he didn't show up
he wasn't they weren't there I tried to
deliver it they can say anything they
want especially if you live in a kind of
building where you have to do some work
and it was raining it was drizzling so I
get somebody being like ah [ __ ] it I'll
say I did this then I'm gonna take off I
think that's what happened and I just
resented the fact to just ladies on her
phone texting me a bunch of nonsense
knowing that she can't say the truth cuz
honestly I wish she would have just been
like yo I stole it
yeah sorry I just didn't feel like
delivering it to your place it was too
complicated by I can respect that but
this idea of trying to make me feel like
she tried to Gaslight me that's what she
did trying to Gaslight me like I don't
know what I'm talking about like I'm
completely mistaken about what happened
in this situation oh I sent a picture
when you sent a picture like something
about the app where you could send a
picture where the food is she easy gonna
just Center
pick take a picture and still take to
food Witter then she stole my food that
chick stole my food Wendy from door - I
know you stole my food I hope you
enjoyed that shrimp scampi burrito from
poquito mas yeah I know was you just
have some pride in a job damn it anyway
topic one done I went all lights out
today those dopes with Josh wolf again
and this lady Ariel Ariel van der
something-or-other I've never I don't
even know who she was but she was real
friendly real dope I had a good I had a
good time with her let me get her name
right you know put her picture up here
there's her picture boom you know yeah
it was fun times we had some fun topics
sometimes I go on the show what's her
last name Vander Berg Ariel Vanderburgh
sometimes you go on the show in the site
sometimes it's like easy topics fun to
riff on and other times it's just like
some weird topics you know especially
was [ __ ] like the corona virus going
around everybody aired of the damp
corona virus you know it's like to me I
don't even know I'm not a scientist so
I'm not gonna speak on it but I don't
know if everything that's happening
right now like what people are trying to
do like don't shake hands gonna meet
don't go near anybody anytime there's a
scare about like you could shut people's
businesses down cuz the Koreatown they
got these good Korean barbecue places
and apparently there was some kind of
scared in that area and then like it
decimated the restaurant business for
like a week like nobody was going to
these restaurants and it's just like dan
that sucks and I was thinking about like
I like getting my they're going to get a
foot rub so I wanted a foot rub place
and he's like a lot of it's just Chinese
foot rub places so like you now we in
this like we all be a racist you know we
all being like well you know the day
they come they don't speak English you
know then they come fresh off the boat
or fresh off the plane and they they
take him to the the place go rub
people's feet you know it's just I don't
know what's going on it was just weird
so when he'll get my foot rub right and
so I had like a first I got a smoothie
and I'm walking around my neighborhood
cause it's like there's like one of
those smoothie places so then I'm
walking I see foot rub there's two of
them I let me go check this out
like getting a good foot rub so I'm
sitting out so I go in and first of all
I don't like going to the foot rub
places where you sitting next to
somebody that you don't know and I don't
know for some reason when you go to some
of these foot rub places they want you
to lay down [ __ ] I don't want to
lay down I just want to sit rub my feet
I want my [ __ ] to be in a bucket why you
know with the hot water and then I want
to be sitting up like this nobody want
you to lay down you know and then like I
come in and this dudes with their shirts
off is [ __ ] under covers but their
underarms and [ __ ] around and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is this it just was weird
you know like it looked like a mass unit
like if you were in like some war it
looked like that like people just laying
on tables and I'm like what the [ __ ] is
he's like just weird ask men cut their
arms and [ __ ] out and so I'm sitting it
and I got my shake right and then it was
just like this mean asian woman is
sitting there she's looking at everybody
you know she's like the overlord of the
place you know home and then she says
something to the dude that was gonna do
my feet she said something to Chinese to
him you know and whatever she [ __ ]
says and then he comes over and takes my
shake from me smoking chocolate he took
it he took my smoothie and I was like
what the [ __ ] and then I look over at
her and she's looking at me like this
she took my smoothie and he like put it
on the ground and like my telling me I
was like what damn I was in the
principal's office like I can't have my
smoothie while I'm getting my feet
rubbed and so the knee they sorta
reclined it up like I'll put it up a
little bit so it wasn't a flat lay down
but I was just like damn you know I got
I got my thirty minutes that I bounced
out of there but I don't know well I was
in there I was thinking to myself I
wonder if this is gonna hurt business
like are people worried about the
coronavirus because you know the lot of
these places are Chinese and I hope not
but I mean people are weird you know how
people are a reactionary they they they
think something's going on and then
they're like you know we got to get out
of here this is you know scary or you
know it just it just steamrolls like I
said what happened in Koreatown like
they you know a lot of the restaurants
they didn't go out of business but it's
just you saw pictures of like no one in
there and a Korean barbeque place that's
got to be devastating because they have
to prepare all that food and and so they
probably wasted a lot of food it's a lot
of money law
for them so I hope we can really like
have some sensible reactions to this but
once it comes to the or new was gonna
come here is it wasn't a matter of if it
was a matter of when so now we have to
figure out what this really means cuz I
don't know anything about it you know
I'm you know I just I don't know what it
is is it it seems like it's like like
terrible flu symptoms or how is it
different from like you know you know
the these other flus and bird flu and
all these other things that we've heard
about in the past it's just like it's
just like a gonna be like this terrible
rampant thing that's gonna like decimate
the population I don't know I'm worried
about in LA you know there's so many
homeless people in LA and they're just
out there on the streets I mean one of
the reasons why the plague spread way
back in the olden times is people
weren't bathing and washing and with it
was in dirty conditions so I'm nervous
about you know these people out here in
these conditions and they just getting
bigger and bigger and bigger it's like
something like that gonna happen I feel
bad for those people that they're living
in these dirty conditions and how are
those dirty conditions gonna affect
everyone else because it's literally
like you think if you think you're
escaping homeless you were [ __ ]
mistaken
I I would venture to say that everybody
in LA is less than a mile away from a
tent ok so at what point are we gonna
step up and do something about this [ __ ]
I don't know how I don't have the
solution but like damn at what point is
it gonna be like a really more horrible
situation you know then it already is so
yeah coronavirus and homeless the two
topics so we talked about the
chronovisor sunlights out then they also
talked about this 38 year old woman
who's gonna be on The Bachelor which i
think is weird I listen she's been on
The Bachelor like three or four times it
didn't work out she got rejected once
she got engaged and then the guy let
they they broke up after a few months
it's like this chick has had her shot
you know and everybody's everybody's on
the internet like oh this is so great
finally a woman of a just like do you
want to see that like do we need a show
to show us that it's difficult to date
as a woman at 38 years old is that is
that we want to show like III don't know
if that's gonna be entertaining you know
I think it's setting her up for failure
in my opinion the lady's beautiful she's
beautiful
okay but what I'm saying is you don't
look at reality shows for reality I mean
that's not what we look but Bachelor is
a train wreck you know it's just like
this whole premise to me I reject I
reject the idea of like you know like
when it's one guy and it's like 50 women
chasing after one whatever how many
women that that how does that make those
women look if they're there on there for
the little paycheck you get in the
notoriety and but it's a train wreck so
why put somebody on there to perpetuate
the train wreck Ignace even more so I
just think that's ridiculous so I don't
know it seems strange to me so I don't
know how it's gonna work and then like
you know again as a guy like what are
you supposed to say about like and what
kind of guys are they gonna have come on
the show like what kind of guys what
kind of guys is they gonna be rich guys
is it gonna be like regular dudes it's
gonna be like this you gotta go on a
show to get a regular dude cuz like when
it's young people you know you go on and
it's like like if it's a Bachelorette
and you go on and there's like you know
12 to 15 of these hunky guys I mean I
get it
these are TV quality guys that you're
going on to like oh let me pick which
one but like she's 38 are they gonna
have also have hunky guys that are
looking for someone like that is it
gonna be a 40 year old guys going for 30
I don't know what see even how I'm
talking about it it sounds terrible you
know you know I mean like how are we
supposed to look at it how he's supposed
to enjoy it and I think all the women
that are tweeting about Oh finally a
woman of age they're just setting this
chick up for failure and two for a sad
situation
hopefully it's not like that but I think
she's had her shot she's been on the
show six times or whatever bachelors in
Paradise bachelor this bad let all the
different types of shows I just what
poor do you go we just not into you
anymore move on but I don't know we'll
see we'll see if it's entertaining
okay what else did I want to talk to you
guys about oh you know what I actually
okay so I was in Canada right I went to
Canada and you know I don't understand
it's like I didn't realize that Netflix
is different everywhere so like when you
looking on the Netflix in Canada there's
actually [ __ ] available that's not
available in the United States like when
I was in Canada uncut gems was on
Netflix
so I was like oh this is cool because I
hadn't seen it yet so actually I'm so
glad I did this I downloaded it onto my
iPad because I wanted to watch it on the
plane home so I started watching and I
didn't finish it but I also watched this
show called Titans and it's a DC
Universe show so they had it on Netflix
and I was like and this show is dope
okay this is my review of this show oh
man I [ __ ] love this because first of
all I didn't think DC was gonna be able
to compete with Marvel cuz they've been
sucking a bag of dicks so far except for
like Wonder Woman
maybe one and then in the original
Batman's not even just the first one
Batman Begins cuz they had so many
tragedies you know with Heath Ledger
dying that kind of messed up what
happened with the second one but anyways
Batman Begins is a great movie change
the whole genre it's a really great
movie but anyways other than those by
DC's been stuck in a bag of dicks so
their TV version it's like Titans I
don't know if you're into DC Comics two
people that are are you honest you know
what the Titans are it's like the you
know it's like Robin you know Robin and
like young Aquaman you're Aqualad and
all these different type of characters
that are amongst the Titans you know so
but the thing I like about this show is
it's rated R they're cursing and there's
blood it's like very adult show and I
love it it's like rated R Robin you know
what I mean and it's it's great it's a
little gets a little campy and it gets a
little you know they probably didn't
have the biggest budget but they tried
their best they probably spent the
budget on the special effects and then
the great costumes and but like again
it's rated R it's an adult show and I
love it
right so
I even downloaded like a few episodes
it's like watching the plane and so but
when I got back to the United States I
sit down on my couch in my oh let me go
watch TV you know Titans and the [ __ ]
was gone
it wasn't on there and I was like oh
[ __ ] where is this turns out you have to
pay you have to subscribe for the DC
Universe streaming service and at first
I was lying but then I went on there and
you could get a free 14-day it's either
a seven-day or 14-day trial because I
wanted to finish watching Titans because
it was dope so I signed up for it it was
like $80 it's like 82 I believe for like
that you pay for the year like $7 a
month but then I look on there and dude
there's comic books all the DC cartoons
like a Superman movie some of the old
Superman shows again new comic books
some great cartoons like the Harley
Quinn cartoon again a bunch of great
stuff on there Plus this show another
one Doom Patrol
I think it's called Doom Patrol actually
let me go to it right now cuz I really
want to make sure I'm getting the [ __ ]
right you know what I mean
entertainment I have it on my phone too
DC Universe yeah it's a great app
actually the app is pretty it's pretty
easy to operate yeah it's called Doom
Patrol and Doom Patrol man dad that [ __ ]
is dope dude you know I'm showing some
[ __ ] about it right here I guess you
know I'm trying to be like you know boom
my edits um yeah this [ __ ] is dope so
now and in Doom Patrol you saw and it
has um oh man why am i forget yeah and I
say I gotta go to the phone again dude I
gotta go let me look up let me just
Brendan Fraser's in it Doom Patrol cast
okay
okay so Deanna Guerro glare oh I think
she's dope she was in orange is the new
black I actually did a pilot with her is
she's great in this she plays like a
crazy character and you got Brendan
Fraser and he he his character is great
Timothy Dalton you know there's a lot of
great people but um they started this
in the Titans like they teased it in the
Titans these characters were armed on
the Titans and then now they have their
own show but it's great you know and
it's like it's this again this one's a
little camp YouTube but this is fun
campy and again right at our another
rated our show so I think DC Universe is
gonna be the rated our branch of DC
Comics and I think they doing the right
thing I think I'm tired of making
everything for kids you know stop making
[ __ ] for kids I get it if it's all about
money but like I'm an adult paying $7 a
month or you know it's like imagine if
Netflix was just all rated G you'd be
like [ __ ] this what am i paying $11 a
month to cater to kids that I don't have
you know and even if you have kids then
you have put the adult monitor on and
you you have the kids version of it so I
do like to a decent universes I don't
know what other shows they're coming out
with because I did a review a couple
some episodes back of like the streaming
wars and I never talked about DC
Universe so if I want to revisit that to
rear anq what I think the things are I
think it's still Netflix is still champ
they're still number one and even more
so now I would go Neph things I would go
Amazon moreover the Disney Plus because
the Disney Plus dude they still haven't
put out any of these new shows maybe
when those shows come out fine they
[ __ ] play demand DeLorean I watched
it I loved it and now for months now
nothing else new is on this [ __ ] so I
think that was a mistake
push it out so I think it goes Netflix
Amazon just because of the choices you
have on Amazon and you can also pay for
things on Amazon - if you're so inclined
like I could actually buy this DC
Universe shows I could have just bought
it on Amazon per episode as opposed to
paying the for the whole thing for the
year and when you think about it
actually paying per episode might
actually be better in the long run if
all you want are those episodes and
nothing else cuz then you're done but if
it's like a dollar two dollars in
episode 10 episodes you know like 30
something I think it's less than the $80
but I'm gonna try to see if I want to
get into the cartoons and the other
comics and then if I don't like it I
just
cancel the [ __ ] but anyways I still
think it's Netflix Netflix is king
I think Amazon and then I think you know
probably Disney plus and then Apple TV
and then whatever the actually I think
Hulu scene I had to do my list of
[ __ ] again let's go Netflix Amazon
Hulu are kind of tied Disney Plus Apple
TV but and then this DC Universe is in
there it just depends on what your
favorite shows are if you really like a
show and I think DC Universe is like I
don't think it can compete with them but
these shows can you know these shows can
definitely compete so I do recommend
like getting rated are Robin Titans
that's what I call it ready to are Robin
and I just do patrol this I'm really
good it's really entertaining show I
actually like Doom Patrol better than I
liked what was that one on HBO whatever
that's superhero one on HBO you guys are
probably saying it in the comments right
now I don't I don't really care what the
[ __ ] name of it was but I didn't lie
I mean it was good they already not
coming back with another season of it so
it's like you don't even matter but I
think Doom Patrol is on par with that
show yeah so make sure you guys you know
listen to that and you know guys make
sure you also check out our girlfriend
comm go to air girlfriend , check out my
my tour dates a website is wonkey as
[ __ ] but I at least have the tour dates
and everything there with links to buy
tickets I'm coming to a town near you
I'm doing a lot of dates coming up in
2020 so make sure you check that out and
then again once again Erling racing
chair i want to thank them for
sponsoring the show they sent me this
really great chair so you saw a little
commercial about that so check that out
and you know keep watching the show I
got some great guests coming up and I'm
just trying to grow the show guys
you know how it is so you know is that
it's that kind of process you know it's
it's a it's a long tedious process of
trying to like you know put out you know
proper high-quality entertain is it even
high-quality entertainment or if it's
just like my mind [ __ ]
you know crazy thoughts I don't know I
guess I'll finish also with the two the
two movies cuz Oscars Oscars been over
but haven't really talked about it but
the two movies I had Matt DeLeon and
when man Thalia was on you know we
talked about nineteen seventeen the only
two movies I felt that should have been
nominated I just could have I'm saying
win best picture was a parasite in 1917
I thought those two movies were just the
ones that stood out in my head as a
great movie going experience so I do
suggest you go out and watch nineteen
seventeen like I didn't know anything
about it I didn't know it was like a
one-shot films when I went to go see it
so when I look in saw that the opening
shot is going on for ten twelve thirteen
minutes I was like they haven't cut they
haven't cut and then I was just
enthralled for the rest of the movie and
parasite takes such an odd turn that you
just gripped from from like you already
were enjoying the movie and then it
takes this odd turn and you're like what
the [ __ ] just happened and now you're
just like wow what a different movie
than anything I've seen you know in
American cinema so you know so I'm glad
that won a bunch of awards too because
once again it was this whole thing about
there's no female directors and all this
[ __ ] it's like I don't you know what I
loved I loved that the Asian movie won
and also won a bunch of other awards
because what can you say when you think
women are underrepresented in Hollywood
try Asian so how can when that happen
you didn't hear [ __ ] cuz what you
supposed to say once again you know it's
like all they could be is like well my
man they were men than a man it's always
Man Man Man Man Man
but like hey Asians are been
underrepresented in Hollywood for
forever you know so here we are this
movie one so that kind of shut up
they're like the feminists who were like
trying to be like well women you know
that one female director she to her I
don't know anyone a movie it was you
know she probably should have been
nominated but I didn't even see the
movie
I personally feel like we should just
split it up like we split up actor you
know like we split up actor and actress
split up the director to female director
male director some people don't like
that I'm sure you're gonna say in the
comments if you like it or not imagine
if they didn't have actor and actress
imagine if they got rid of that they
just said who had the best performance
it would be a nightmare every year
because sometimes it's gonna be five
white guys it might be five white guys
that actually gave the best performance
what are you supposed to do now we have
to like cast it we have to be like well
let's make sure so they knew a long time
ago let's not even put people in that
situation let's just split it up male
female well split everything up then you
know split everything up so everybody
can get an award because that's what
they want let's just give everybody an
award you know then you know just I
don't know takes away from it I want
everybody to have an opportunity and
have chances though you know it's like
at the development stage is where we
should really be working on this I've
talked about this before I'm not gonna
talk about it again but at the
development stage but until that
development stage comes this is what we
have to deal with these are the movies
that are in our face let's [ __ ] vote
on these movies and unfortunately
they're gonna be movies worse
all men are you know all something you
know and occasionally someone's gonna
break through like a parasite or
whatever the female directors and you
know female performers and all that kind
of stuff so we'll see what happened but
anyways that's a quickie I just wanted
to come out with a quick riffing with
Griffin solo riffing mid week solo
riffing I'll do more of them you know
send me messages of movies you want me
to review TV shows all your questions
you have for me send them to email me at
Eric at Eric Griffin got calm just solo
riffing in the in the subject or you
know so you can send me messages
anywhere that you know I Instagram
whatever you say hey man talk about this
on your solo episode I would love to
because I want to start doing more maybe
maybe once a week I don't know at the
same time still trying to get a movie
review show going with some
most likely gonna be Steve that every
time I have somebody on my podcast that
does that review that they we have a
great conversation people go you should
do a podcast with that person you know I
can't do a podcast with everyone
guys maybe is me maybe I'm just the one
that has great chemistry with people you
ever think of that but I don't know I go
to my own horn you want just did but
once again thanks for listening watching
I want thank bugs bu ggs he's on
Instagram for that dope beat he sent me
and you know let's let I'll see you guys
next week not sure who's gonna be on the
next episode of Griffin with Griffin but
I got Jamie Kennedy in the queue I got
Christopher DeStefano in the queue hope
I said his name miner is a Christian
it's Christopher a Christian not sure
but uh you know keep watching keep
listening share subscribe and I really
appreciate all of you even you troll
[ __ ] I sometimes like you guys too
but thanks for watching this solo
episode of peace
[Music]